Nos dicen: "Jana y Alfredo consiguieron
unas plantas para sus respectivos hogares.
Ambos midieron el crecimiento de sus
plantas. La de Jana crece, en promedio,
2 centímetros por semana. La de Alfredo
crece, en promedio, 3 milímetros por día.
¿Qué planta crece más rápido?" Pausa el video
e intenta encontrar la respuesta por tu cuenta.
Bien, vamos a trabajar juntos. Tal vez, al
principio, cuando vemos este problema, podríamos
simplemente comparar 2 con 3 y decir "Tres es más
grande que dos, por lo tanto, la planta de Alfredo
crece más rápido". Y podríamos creer esto hasta
que vemos las unidades: la planta de Jana se mide
en centímetros por semana, mientras que la planta
de Alfredo está en milímetros por día; entonces,
para compararlas realmente, necesitamos que
tengan las mismas unidades, tanto en longitud como
en tiempo. Así que pasemos ambas unidades a...,
¿qué te parece centímetros por semana? Podríamos
intentar convertir ambas unidades en milímetros
por día o incluso en metros por año, es decir,
un tercer conjunto de unidades, pero centímetros
por semana suena razonable. Así que ya tenemos la
tasa de crecimiento de la planta de Jana, vamos a
escribirlo: la planta de Jana, que denotaremos con
la letra J, crece 2 cm / semana, mientras que la
de Alfredo crece, en promedio, 3 mm / día. Ahora,
¿cómo convertimos 3 milímetros por día en
centímetros por semana? Bueno, primero podríamos
convertir los días a semanas. ¿Cuántos días hay
en una semana? Bueno, son 7 días por semana,
entonces, si tenemos cierta cantidad de milímetros
por día y queremos saber cuántos milímetros por
semana son, entonces tenemos que multiplicar
esa cantidad por 7 días. Vamos a hacerlo:
por 7 días / semana, esto nos dará 3 x 7 = 21 mm
/ semana. Podemos ver que las unidades se cancelan
bastante bien y, por lo tanto, nos quedamos con
milímetros por semana. Y esto tiene sentido:
si crece 3 milímetros por día y la semana tiene 7
días, entonces va a crecer siete veces eso en una
semana: 21 mm / semana. Bien, ahora necesitamos
pensar en cuántos centímetros son 21 milímetros.
Bueno, debemos recordar que 1 centímetro es igual
a 10 milímetros, entonces, si queremos convertir
esto en centímetros, tenemos que dividir entre
10, es decir, 1 / 10 cm / mm. Esto nos dará,
bueno, podemos escribirlo de varias formas;
las unidades se cancelan bastante bien,
21 / 10 es 2.1 cm / semana. Otra forma de pensarlo
es la siguiente: podemos decir que 1 cm = 10 mm,
o si dividimos de ambos lados por 10 tenemos que,
1/10 cm = 1 mm y si 1 milímetro es igual a 1/10 de
centímetro entonces 21 milímetros serán 21 veces
esto: 21 x 1/10 es 21 dividido entre 10 que es 2.1
centímetros. Ahora es buen momento de comparar:
2.1 cm / semana con 2 cm / semana, bueno, resulta
que cuando comparamos las unidades adecuadas la
planta de Alfredo crece ligeramente más rápido.